it's perfect for anyone sitting in the
grandstands at the speedway this weekend
or maybe even for those camping out oh
absolutely Logan reefer is doing just
that he's there inside a Johnny Walker
RV hey Logan
hey guys yeah I you mentioned how nice
the weather is it's perfect weather to
just go inside of an RV and not do
anything for hours on end isn't that
really what it is the perfect day when
it comes to this so we're still getting
prepared as a lot of other people they
prepare here for move-in day most of the
RVs joining me as you mentioned the
Johnny Walker RV loud and proud making
its way or stationary currently but
making its way metaphorically through
all these parking lots as everybody else
gets ready for this race and you know
Vegas is the destination when it comes
to not just the speedway but you look
around the rest of the country and that
is because of the people that come out
of Vegas when it comes to drivers you
look at Kyle Busch Bush his brother Kurt
obviously the legends of the sport then
there's the new guys you got Noah
Gregson Riley herps you'll hear from him
in a little bit but even the folks at
NASCAR you know they take note of what
is happening here in Vegas and better
yet who is coming out of Vegas
well NASCAR loves Las Vegas and Las
Vegas loves NASCAR because these dry
look at these drivers that have come out
of the city I mean with the Bush
Brothers with with Kurt and Kyle being
so successful go all the way back with
Brendan gone and his career that he had
here in in all levels of NASCAR and the
success that he had and then you look at
the drivers coming up like you know
Riley Herbst and then you know of course
Noah Gregson who said a NASCAR Xfinity
series record earlier this season by
winning four consecutive races and he
has seven wins on the season it's
incredible to see the amount of talent
that has come out of one metropolitan
area
you know what's funny you heard from him
there he that's not even a Vegas guy
he's from the Midwest but the passion in
which he talks about Vegas and the
drivers from here you can really tell
that it's left a profound impact on the
rest of the people in the sport speaking
of impact coming up at six o'clock we'll
have a historic story from you the first
mother-daughter pair to ever race in the
same event in not just ARCA history but
NASCAR history that story is coming up
for you later on at six o'clock but in
the meantime from the Johnny Walker RV
Logan Reaver eight Sports now all right
Logan really does have an amazing seat
up there all right just a reminder
Logan's pit stop from his Johnny Walker
RV continues through Sunday following
the South Point 400. little do the
people who move and know he'll be
knocking on their doors at 4am hey we
got to get a live shot for the morning
show oh yeah look out